hi Sophie well we're going to talk to uh
vihad baheshti in just a couple of
seconds but you can have a look at his
encampment here tents and flowers and
and other items he's been here for 30
days outside the foreign and
Commonwealth office he wants the British
government to designate the
Revolutionary guards of Iran or the irgc
as a terrorist organization or
essentially put them in the same
category as say Isis or Al-Qaeda and
they are a notorious group thought
partly responsible for the suppression
of popular protests that we've been
seeing in Iran over the last six months
vahid has been on a hunger strike for 30
days you are quite weak you haven't had
anything to eat a couple of a cup of
coffee and some sugar cubes I'm told a
little bit of water how how are you
doing
I'm I'm still standing surviving yes as
you describe I'm getting weaker
physically but internally I'm getting
stronger and I'm determined and certain
to carry on till we achieve this great
goal for not just Iranian people or the
or the people of Ukraine this who do
these days get killed by the irgc Drone
which Supply to Putin
I'm here I'm carrying this protest and
hunger stroke for our fellow British
citizens because today we experience the
hands of and we see the hands of all
your GC here in London when Metropolitan
Police few weeks ago asked Iran
International TV station to relocate
from London to DC because of the threat
of irgc that means we are not safe here
because of the threat of oogc and I will
continue this the Revolutionary guards
are accused of having operations at home
and externally as well MI5 has released
a report about their activities in
countries like the UK why this form of
protest this extreme form of protest I
mean you may damage your health you
could even lose your life doing this and
first uh we didn't start it from here
we've been in talk and talk and
conversation
and we had two conference in Parliament
about this issue and the process was
going smoothly suddenly we experienced
there is an obstacle from our contacts
and few MPS we heard we understand the
obstacle is from foreign office okay and
then the talk didn't work and I what I
would like to show our leaders and
politicians there are still people who
they are willing to pay whatever price
in order to defend our values British
values freedom and democracy and our
rights here and I'm willing to do this
and continue this hunger struct till we
achieve this together so you think you
have support from some MPS government
MPS as well but you haven't had any word
from the foreign secretary basically
against basically or can loudly say we
have the majority of MPS with us we have
Tom Mr Tom tugenhart Mr Miss soiler they
all are produce even Mr Rishi sunak
before he elected as our prime minister
he has stated in one tweet irgc should
be placed on the list of terrorist
organizations so we have them all they
agree with that the only obstacle is
from this building for an office and
hopefully by a little bit of motivation
we will achieve this okay very quickly
we're joined here also by Richard
Ratcliffe the husband of nasanine who
was held by the Revolutionary guard for
six years you know something about this
form of protest as well I've been on
this very very spot in a tent like that
for 21 days so this is 30 days that was
incredibly hard
um and again didn't do that lightly it
felt like it was a long battle I feel an
awful lot for whatever he's going
through
um and and yes as you say it's it's a
visceral former protest he's trying to
make a clear statement to the front
office to reconsider this policy to
explain why you're not doing it and I
hope that they'll listen the government
has said look just a couple of days ago
we placed sanctions on senior members of
the irgc the Revolutionary guards we do
take this issue seriously we are acting
on this yeah like I think it's good
whenever the government sanctions any
wrongdoing I think if you think in our
case I always felt the government would
stop peddling in response to Iran's
hostage taking would treat it like it
was a domestic human rights issue for
Iran and not really a security issue
um but he's right when you have the
situation of British journalists being
threatened on the Streets of London
that's not okay and you know I think the
government does need to look seriously
what it can do okay thank you very much
Richard Radcliffe from foreign and
Commonwealth office we will hand you
back to to London now